[Music]
in communist behavior news submitted by
I am the law it just reminds me a bark
calling everyone communists on his
[ __ ] is the ground you did well with
that it was just random like haters they
right right something stupid and then I
never entertain them so I was just right
back something crazy and then usually
confuses them that makes me happy
that should be the thing just whoever is
talking [ __ ] call I'm a communist
[ __ ] it's so good that someone wrote
something on one of my one of my picture
to use it and I roll oh [ __ ] you yeah
[ __ ] you you communist dick right and
what's great about it is this guy's
probably like he bought your punk ass
[ __ ] or whatever right and then he gets
back like you're a [ __ ] communist and
he Cinelli's it yeah I'm a cop yeah a
teacher sparked a debate online after he
was filmed wiping makeup off female
students faces sounds bad damn why is
that bad maybe they had too much makeup
maybe they didn't maybe they didn't
consent him just like robbing [ __ ]
people
oh you think I'm so aggressively going
up like this
that's throw on my teacher does remove
like a face what if he's touching it up
for you
I need the probational Michael it's a
makeup clothing at all from me gee what
a few extra [ __ ] for distracting for
him okay I get it he couldn't contain
himself otherwise right what if he
rubbed it off and then applied some
better makeup on you oh god I'd be
[ __ ] offended that's that he's got
the Avon [ __ ] is the [ __ ] is [ __ ] elf is
the shittiest [ __ ] it's one dollar Avon
is worse than elderly Avon ladies are
all do that's why they had bad makeup I
just pictured them you're right that's
like Mary Kay
those are the books wrecked chicks [ __ ]
but they got that pink car yeah they got
the pink car but they got [ __ ] pink
cheeks too
holy [ __ ] with the pink BMW I didn't
know they were [ __ ] existed still I
don't know that's what I'm saying
I just remember when I was a kid I was
like oh [ __ ] yeah alright so this story
here this is a teacher in China
Indiana China
in Wisconsin is worth the show well I
mean that's settled
humming this behavior yeah so this
Chinese schoolteacher a lot of Chinese
plots like to come to our videos that
are anti China it's not even anti-china
we just like to make jokes
so they okay so this teacher it's a
secondary school teacher used a cloth to
wipe down aggressively wipe down these
female students makeups was it
microfiber oh that really works
yeah can be really soft yeah she needed
to use makeup remover cuz it's really
thick on the skin
microfiber works too though oh yeah just
using the cloth just water in cloth is
that right the teacher didn't even use
water that's why so aggressively I will
show you a video I use that on the
glasses there's the video well here you
go
oh goody there's water there's water the
bucket of water what is he doing he's
[ __ ] using that [ __ ] like he's trying
to buff their face like it's a car but
it's a lot he's lining up for it early
and then he uses the same cloth damn
bucket yeah it's a bucket damn it he
just pulling by her hair damn are they
all laughing it's a dude teacher no
they're just like damn what the [ __ ] is
it against ur dress code or something
yeah like unless I know like I do oh
yeah I want to talk [ __ ] I want to work
this school said that in rule and this
rule rule rule roll air we oven we're
out
ruh-roh many students have been wearing
heavy makeup to class and the school
decided to ban makeup oh it's not rule
anymore most of these students are the
Left Behind children whose parents live
in work in big cities so they're their
fourth teachers felt the responsibility
to look after them and provide them with
proper guidance it sounds like the
Chinese Lancaster they don't even have
like latchkey kids they have left behind
heads left behind that's really
depressing that's like I'm left there to
[ __ ] fend for my own while my parents
go work and send me money
that's kind of cool that is kind of cool
just send money but latchkey kids are
sad though Nikki was one help and the
damage is done
I feel like ask me how I know you know
my friend was a parachute kid and I was
like man you are so lucky
we were special a parachute kid is like
the reverse of this where your parents
are so [ __ ] rich they send off their
kids to America on little parachutes and
then they [ __ ] land here and then
they have to fend for themselves and
he's just inject a [ __ ] ton of money on
for yourself I'd say that's kind of like
cuz they have like good amount though
it's like the military school you had no
license but his parents are like this
kid needs to get around so I'll buy a
house I'll give you a car you figure out
how to drive it and go to drive yourself
to high school it sounds kind of dope
but I get it I get that it's not but
yeah but right now it sounds dope oh
yeah totally it does it's it well I was
always jealous like well cuz my friend
it was him and his little brother and
then they would always like stay at
these homes like I guess their
caretakers or whatever and he's like I
can't get along with any of them so the
parents just [ __ ] bottom a place and
then had like a man your maid
live on the townhouse behind oh my god
so she would just come over take care of
[ __ ] and him and his brother would have
the whole house themselves so we'll be
playing like Dance Dance Revolution til
2:00 a.m. yeah and then he would make
buckin like he would cook we just you
Dave would just stock his like house
with groceries we would just [ __ ]
make food this was like 7th or 8th grade
dude I heard Eminem has a Taco Bell in
his in his mansion because my [ __ ]
wife is obsessed with a man I know it's
[ __ ] uh looks like you know his mom
just sue them again again well maybe
that's something that's old that sounds
pretty I think perhaps it's 10 million
things I don't know what the amount was
I just know that his mom's been all over
him I recently met this lady that was a
parachute kid and like I had never met
anyone like
that's only what she was telling me
stories that when she was in high school
she Asian yeah um her is from Taiwan so
then she was telling me that in high
school on she grew up in San Marino okay
there's a ton of them yeah is it
especially around that area yes of
course of course a marina San Marino in
Arcadia they have a lot of parachute
kids there it's like really Hills
yeah millionaire billionaire kids
Taiwanese I'm updating so then thank you
so then uh just telling me that in in
school her guardian would take her to
the grocery store and just stock up on a
fuckton of alcohol and she'd throw these
crazy parties all the time and I'm like
what a dog Guardian I know right it's
not a guardian that's a servant she
calls that person a guardian and then
she said that there was this one time
that she drank like her her friend's
strength is like mega expensive whiskey
that were like it's worth like thousands
of dollars and then that they ever she
didn't know how expensive it was so she
drank it like her new friends jacket and
as she refilled it with with teeth so
then her dad comes with a whole bunch of
really important executive people yeah
and then she got in so much time like
smoothies Japanese whiskey yeah which
one which one I don't know cuz the
bottle looked like a foreign language to
me
Aki really Bom yeah they make good
whiskey yeah over price but did they
make it whiskey yeah so I was at this
like [ __ ] trade show thing that you
all got invited to by the way but nobody
came to except for me and Nikki and
alcohol thing on Monday goes doing oh I
should have gone no I'm really quit it
cuz I'm gonna drinking I will make sure
that you're invited next time it was
[ __ ] awesome and you got to try
everything they had everything there was
so sick so yeah I tried Japanese whisky
wow that's really smooth is really is
there really the very meticulous and
comes in details of that kind of [ __ ]
pulse be like one of the top five
whiskey's in the amazake
18 or something like that like the with
the best whiskey of all time and that's
why the price is like shot up like crazy
room like that's why I think the
Japanese whiskey is overpriced is
because there's too much hype around it
so I think that there are better
gotchas for the money but as far as like
whiskey's go it's good it's just not
worth like [ __ ] five times over or
sticker you know so that's like my only
thing with it and I didn't point at Ryan
because he's Japanese I played around
because we've been talking about I know
everyone thinking I'm a racist so it's
all good
well he wouldn't be racist to this
pointing out the right type of Asian
thank you that's what I thought good
point anyway yeah we were talking about
the Chinese teacher with a makeup cloth
yeah that's I think it's totally fine is
it you need to beat some kids up you
just ask them nicely to take it off and
like okay so they're saying now that
like the school is saying that since
that happened no one has gone to school
that makeup anymore that's like do you
know when when someone commits a crime
you hang them in the village and you
leave them up there yeah okay
they have different it's a different
world out there and also if if it is
against the rules then I guess for them
it justifies why they could put hands on
the student and Chinese people don't
talk about problems they just handle it
what's woke in China right now can we
talk about what's wok moves there I mean
you know what Hong Kong's trying to be
woke right now but they're not talking
about that Hong Kong is whoa they're
pretty whoa I heard they were singing
the national anthem you know it's funny
I saw this whole Hong Kong protest thing
and someone showed a picture of this
like protest in Oregon in Portland right
they're all waving the [ __ ] communist
flag there and in Hong Kong
they're waving the [ __ ] American flag
and they're singing the national anthem
what kind of [ __ ] ironic [ __ ] is this
dude it's people who need freedom and
people who think they don't they don't
have or do you think that communism is
freedom yeah what the [ __ ] nuts aren't
the people in Hong Kong protesting with
manga hats on to video just like Donald
Trump don't trust China Chinese [ __ ]
yeah
don't you believe me that's it there
like that comes like you I would do that
too
I'd do it if I was over there and I
wanted America's help I'm wearing
[ __ ] Trump hats shirts whatever help
China is [ __ ] with so angry funny
that's crazy
[Music]